IF YOU'VE GOT MORE TROUBLE THAT
I DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE START TONIGHT WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WE'VE GOT MASSIVE BREAKING NEWS.
ABUSE DID OCCUR.
WE'VE GOT CONFIRMATION.
WE'LL TELL YOU MORE ABOUT IT.
ALSO, COMING UP, HE WILL BE WITH
YOU FOR THE BRAND-NEW EVIDENCE.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE FAKE OUTRAGE.
FIRST IT'S COLLUSION, BENNETT'S
OBSTRUCTION.
NOW IT'S RACISM.
THE EVOLUTION OF THE LEFT'S
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE IS BEYOND
DESPERATE AND PREDICTABLE, AND
DESPICABLE AT THE SAME TIME.
NOW, MOMENTS AGO, THE
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED HOUSE
VOTED TO CONDEMNED PRESIDENT
TRUMPS LOVE IT OR LEAVE IT.
THE SPECIAL CONGRESS WOMAN OMAR,
SPEAKER PELOSI CALLED THE
PRESIDENT A RACIST.
THE FUNNY PART IS, IT WAS ONLY A
FEW DAYS AGO WHEN THE SQUAD
LEADER, CONGRESSMAN DOMINIC ALEA
LEADER, CONGRESSMAN DOMINIC ALED
LEADER, CONGRESSMAN DOMINIC ALEI
LEADER, CONGRESSMAN DOMINIC ALEA
OCASIO-CORTEZ ACCUSED
NANCY PELOSI OF PICKING OUT
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND RACISM.
REMEMBER THOSE SAME DEMOCRATS,
THEY REFUSED TO CONDEMN ILHAN
OMAR FOR HER CONSTANT, VILE,
ANTI-SEMITIC REMARKS?
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN
OVER THERE.
THESE FOUR RADICAL CONGRESSWOMEN
RUN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
THEY ARE IN CONTROL, PRETTY MUCH
OF THE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
NOW, THE FOUR RADICALS, TWO OF
WHICH ARE BIGOTED ANTI-SEMITES
ARE NOW SETTING THE AGENDA FOR
THE ENTIRE PARTY TONIGHT IN JUST
A FEW MINUTES, WE ARE GOING TO
PROVIDE CONTEXT.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL HANNITY
HISTORY LESSON ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
A HISTORY WITH RACE.
THEIR RAPID HYPOCRISY.
THEIR SHAMEFUL POLITICAL